of course jeff science our kobut
coordinator and dr fauci
to uh talk about the news from the fda
this morning they're also going to be
able to take some questions i will keep
an eye on
the clock and with that i will turn it
over to jeff
well first thank you jen and thank you
to all of you um
good afternoon as you all know uh the
fda and cdc announced earlier today that
out of abundance of caution
they've recommended a pause in the use
of johnson johnson vaccine
as they review data involving six
reported u.s cases of a rare and severe
type of blood clot in individuals after
receiving the johnson johnson
vaccine let me start by saying that this
announcement will not have a significant
impact on our vaccination program the j
j vaccine makes up less than five
percent
of the more than 190 million recorded
shots
in arms in the united states to date
the president has always said that this
is a wartime
effort we're at war against the virus
and as such we've mobilized a wartime
effort so we're prepared for a wide
range of scenarios
and that's why the president took action
earlier this year
before the jnj vaccine was even
authorized
to secure enough pfizer and moderna
doses for 300 million americans
by the end of july
over the last few weeks we have made
available more than
25 million doses of pfizer and moderna
each and every week in fact this week
we will make available 28 million doses
of these two vaccines
and as we've done since we took office
we will continue to get the supply out
the door
as soon as it's available so we have
more than enough supply of pfizer
and modern vaccines to continue the
current pace
of about 3 million shots per day
and that puts us well on pace to meet
the president's goal of 200 million
shots
by his 100th day in office
and continue to reach every adult who
wants to get
vaccinated we're now working with our
state
and federal partners to get anyone
scheduled for j
j vaccine quickly rescheduled for a
pfizer
or moderna vaccine and we're actually
already seeing this happen
today at sites across the country
where jnj appointments are being
adjusted
that were for today to actually get
madonna and pfizer
today so that's happening many places
across the country
the president has committed to the
american people that his administration
will always lead with science
tell the truth and give americans the
facts as we know them
cdc and fda will continue to do just
that
and provide regular updates to the
public
and they will do so as they continue
their investigation
with that let me hand it over to dr
fauci and then we'll take questions
thank you very much jeff um just to
follow up a bit and maybe
uh fill in a couple of points
from what jeff said and what our
colleagues in the fda in the cdc
said uh earlier this morning
at the press conference uh a couple of
issues
uh come up of of the importance of
of uh calling this pause because people
say what does the pause mean
it really allows both the fda and the
cdc to further investigate
these cases to try and understand
some of the mechanisms of what it is
some more details about the history of
the individuals who are involved that
might
shed some light on looking forward what
will happen and what we will do that's
the first thing
the other thing is to make physicians
out there
aware of this and there are some
clinical implications of that that i
believe
are important for example if someone
comes in
with this really rather rare syndrome of
thrombotic thrombocytopenia where you
get thrombosis and when you have
thrombosis the most common way to treat
that is with heparin
that would be a mistake in this
situation because it could be dangerous
and make the situation
much worse so there's a clinically
relevant reason why you want to make
this
known to people also when individuals
particularly
younger women who might come into a
physician
with a particular thrombotic phenomenon
which is things that
happen for other reasons all the time
that we want to alert physicians to take
a history of a recent
vaccination that would be important so
the pause not only allows us to take a
look at the cases and learn more
but it is also a signal out there to
help the physicians
a common question and i'm sure we'll
have a number of questions which jeff
and i will be
happy to answer to you but one of the
questions
that comes up already rather frequently
does this have anything to do
with the efficacy of the vaccine so we
know that there have been 6.85
million doses of j and j distributed in
the united states thus far
so someone who maybe had it a month or
two ago would say
what does this mean for me it really
doesn't mean anything you're okay
because if you look at the frame the
time
frame when this occurs it's pretty tight
from a few days six to 13 days
from the time of the vaccination the
next question is one that we're all
obviously aware of what impact is this
going to have about people's attitudes
about vaccines in general so you might
know that there have been now uh
120 million people that have received
at least one dose of a vaccine most of
that
subtract the 6.85 million is in the
messenger rna from fisa
and from moderna there have been no
red flag signals from those
so you're talking about tens and tens
and tens of millions of people who've
received vaccine with no
adverse effect this is a really rare
event
if you look at what we know so far there
have been six
out of the six 6.85 million doses which
is less
than one in a million so remember this
is something that
we always out of a really out of an
abundance of caution
as jeff said to give us a time to take a
good look at it
and see if we can get further
information so i'll stop there
jeff and we could obviously take some
questions
you described this as a really rare
event but this does seem like a pretty
drastic step
do you believe that the scientists
sufficiently weighed the benefits of
this pause
against the damage or risk that this
could do to the broader effort and the
impact it could have on vaccine
hesitancy
well dr fauci um maybe you'll go after
me but i want to say that we have
plenty of supply so i mentioned that we
for the last
several weeks have been sending 25
million doses
out and while we're averaging 3 million
shots in arms per day
uh the 25 million supports actually that
level and even accelerating
and we just sent out 28 million doses
today or announced 28 million doses will
be sent this week
the state's tribe territories and
through our federal channels so we have
plenty of supply to continue our
vaccination program and to hit our goals
but over there i believe your question
is
did we pull the trigger too soon on this
because it was such a rare event
well you know the our fda is
internationally known
for their capability of making sure that
we have
uh this morning and therefore had no
other involvement
other than knowing last night that there
would be an announcement this morning
for the fda in the city
and then this review what what's going
to happen what are they looking for what
are they
evaluating when should we expect a
conclusion well they want to see if
there's any clues of other things going
on were there any underlying
for example if they're going to just a
hypothetical
if they're going to make a decision to
go forward and say you know we looked at
this
if they find some common denominators
among the women
who were involved that might be
synergizing and
essentially enabling this type of an
adverse event
they may know that for those who don't
have that
it may be much safer there may be clues
when you go down and
really get granular about every single
case
in addition they want to look at what
some of the mechanisms are
the mechanisms may give some insight as
to what is going on
should we expect the potential to see
further causes in the future i mean
could this keep happening with the
vaccines because they're so new
well you know if you look at the history
of take a look at what has gone on
with the moderna and the pfizer where
you have you know literally tens and
tens and tens of millions
let's watch this carefully there have
been no
red flags when you have a red flag of
something
that is as serious as thrombotic
thrombocytic pena
particularly when you have an individual
one of whom died
you take that seriously so i don't think
that
minimal things that very likely have
nothing at all to do with the vaccine
that we're going to pull the trigger so
quickly as to keep stopping and stopping
and stopping
i think this is an unusual occurrence of
a serious
adverse event that you want to make sure
before you go forward
you investigate it thoroughly and that's
exactly what they're doing they're
pausing
so that they can look at it more
carefully thank you that's
a couple for dr falchi first it's great
to see you back at the podium dr falcon
um given that the impacted patients were
all women
between the ages of 18 and 48
should women under 50 be excluded from
getting the jnj vaccine the question
you're asking
gets back to several of the questions
here that's the reason why the cdc and
the fda
want to take a look at this and say is
there are there some categories
now where people outside of that
categories don't have any of the factors
so it'll be okay to go on it is entirely
conceivable making no predictions
that there may be some restriction in an
age group or not we don't know that now
that's the reason why
they're working very hard to answer the
question you're asking
and what's your medical advice for
people who have recently
received the jnj vaccine and may be
concerned about
blood clots well i mean if someone
recently within days i would tell them
to just first of all
don't get an anxiety reaction because
remember it's less than one
in a million however having said that
pay attention
do you have symptoms headache you have
shortness of breath chest discomfort do
you have anything that
resembles a neurological syndrome and
obviously
if you have something as serious as a
seizure i mean you
that's pretty clear but the
manifestations of this are that headache
is the very common
component of it because the sinus
thrombosis that they have
is the draining of the blood in the
brain and it will cause
enough symptomatology to make you notice
it just tell people to just watch out
for not feeling very well and one for
jeff um
officials from different states told us
this morning that they were really
caught off guard by this announcement
they were ready to put shots into
people's arms and had to scramble
can you explain that chain of
communication when
and how did you notify states that they
might have to pause right well as i said
we didn't know about anything
in terms of the announcement until last
night and we didn't even know the
content of the announcement until this
morning when everyone else read it
as soon as we got that we our team
farmed out
and started contacting folks to make
sure that everyone knew that that was
uh now announced by the fda and cdc
tuesday is the day that i have my
regular governor's call
so that was fortunate that that was at
11 a.m we had all the governors already
lined up
with their teams and we had doctors
fauci and dr zwelinski join that call
and the teams will continue to support
the state
wide effort the federal channels the
community health centers
to make the adjustments so i think the
message got out very clearly and quickly
there was no heads up here the
announcement was made this morning
um thanks guys just a few quick ones the
first one and you might not have the
answer to this do we have a timeline in
terms of how long this is going to be
days before it might get flipped back on
or week and then
second one project if you don't i
understand what you're saying on the
macro level
related supply when you talk to local
officials the j and j
shop because of storage because it was
one shot was considered a crucial
component
in rural areas and kind of underserved
communities how does that not affect
the timeline that you guys are on in
terms of actually getting shots and arms
um during one of the questions which was
asked i believe
of the cdc the anat the the question was
just yours
and i don't know what they're going to
be doing what i heard
from the previous press uh discussion
was it's going to be more like days to
weeks rather than weeks to months
we have plenty of supply and we have
plenty of vehicles for delivering that
supply whether it's through the federal
pharmacy channel
whether it's mobile units community
health centers
and all of those are equipped to deliver
um the modern and pfizer
vaccine so we'll make sure that those
units continue to grow
in number because you're right we need
to reach people where they are
and the mobile units in the community
health centers are particularly
essential for those and they have been
receiving
dernan pfizer those assistants could be
on both those programs
it's no different you just swap out the
vaccine if it was a mass vaccination
center or if it was a mobile unit going
to a rural area
yeah madonna and pfizer vaccines as you
know are two dose vaccines
so it's important that people come back
for their second dose three weeks
post their first dose of pfizer and four
weeks post their
first dose of madonna but all you
all of our units all of our delivery
channels are equipped to
deliver both pfizer and just real quick
how does this not contribute to
those are the very areas where hesitancy
i think is most predominant at this
point in time based on what you guys
have seen
do you have to change your message do
you have to do something different
to address hesitancy in the wake of
something i think we need to continue to
be
transparent about what the science is
telling us that's what brings us here
today there's as dr thought she said
there's been tens of millions of doses
of pfizer and moderna um administered
over the last several months and
millions of people
both in the u.s and around the world
there have been safely
vaccinated i think it's important that
you know we have here the fda and the
fda
is the gold standard for ensuring the
safety and the effectiveness of the
vaccines and today's action i think is
clear evidence
that they're taking every step necessary
to ensure
the american people have clear and
transparent information
about the safety and effectiveness of
these vaccines so the bottom line is the
vaccines moderna
and pfizer that are now being
administered um are
clearly safe and are saving lives and
every american should get vaccinated
when it's their turn
nice uh jeff is the is jj
production going to continue uh during
this pause and
uh secondly is the bind administration
considering ordering more doses
of pfizer moderna given i mean just in
case this
problem with j j becomes prolonged so
the j
j production issues in baltimore
obviously a completely separate set of
issues and those are
being worked out through the fda process
with the company
the production of of those vaccines
begin
if and when the fda authorizes that
facility
your second question was you know we
really have thought of this as a wartime
effort from the beginning
which is why we purchased uh excess
supply so we'd be ready for any
contingency and we'll continue to look
at every possibility
in terms of making sure that we always
have enough supply for the american
people well just to clarify on the j j
production uh not related to the
baltimore plant but just overall j j
production
is that going to pause while this pause
on administering doses
occurs or is the production going to
continue well the production is really
centered around that baltimore
facility the vast majority of production
is that baltimore facility
andrew just want to adjust the doctor's
country
and when to just ask you very directly
are you ruling out the possibility that
the vaccine could be
removed from the market i mean are you
ruling out that
are you expecting it to be re-allowed
you know i think it would be premature
to comment on that and that's the reason
the pause was done so that they could
take a good look
at it very carefully look at every
different factor i
i wouldn't want to speculate as to what
what would happen
often when you see things like this that
you pause and come back whether or not
that happens now i can't guarantee it
but i can tell you that's exactly what
the cdc and fda people are going to be
deciding on and looking at very
carefully
just ask you on this outreach so
you know this is the problem that you've
been struggling with
this sort of vaccine hesitancy this
obviously is a setback
how what do you have to sort of ramp up
into an additional
war type effort to really ensure that
this message gets
out there do you personally go to slave
states like mississippi where the
vaccine
vaccination rate is really low okay
that's your
first question you know we
consistent with it being a wartime
effort we've planned for different
scenarios of contingencies
so we have enough supply of moderna and
pfizer
to hit the targets that we've set the
200 million shots in 100 days and to
head toward the fourth of july that
we've talked about as a country a more
normal fourth of july
clearly part of that is making sure that
when it's
an american's turn to get vaccinated
they get vaccinated and we do need to
continue to build
confidence and that's done at the
community level people
are trusting of their local doctors
their faith leaders their neighbors
which is why it's important when people
do get vaccinated they not only
get themselves vaccinated but they
spread the word about the safety and
effectiveness
of the vaccines okay just to nail it
down
one of the goals that you haven't
mentioned today is the hope that
there'll be enough supply on hand for
the country by the end of may
is that still operative now in the wake
of this pause
and the second question is it's a bit
surprising to learn that you only
yourself learned about this this morning
do you wish you had heard sooner
yeah i learned about it last night that
there would be an announcement not the
specifics of the announcement no because
that's to the science and we want the
science agencies to lead with science
and there's no reason for us to be
involved in any of the scientific
decisions we bring nothing to the table
that is the fda's role that is the cdc's
role
and they're led by terrific leaders with
great teams to do the science and this
administration will be led by science
and as to your first question we believe
there's enough vaccination there's
vaccine in the system moderna and pfizer
um for all americans who want to get
vaccinated by may 31st to do so
yeah jeff i could i feel like we're kind
of dancing around the hesitancy question
here and so i
just asked you directly do you think the
announcement of this pause
will increase or decrease vaccine
hesitancy
look hesitancy amongst a group of people
is a challenge
and we need to be addressing it and we
are as i've talked about by going
to to meet people where they are
to follow all that we've learned about
who people
trust doctor local doctor their nurse
um their faith leader and i think that
you know there's tremendous
track record as dr fauci has talked
about with tens of millions of doses of
pfizer and moderna
the fda acting the way they did today
shows that they are indeed the gold
standard and i think that should
reassure the american
public that it will be very diligent
and uh conservative in how they approach
the vaccine
so the argument is that because the fda
this tripwire was triggered
that should give americans more
confidence in the overall
vaccination plan certainly about around
how safety
and efficacy are being monitored by the
gold standard folks at the fda okay
let's do these three more and then we'll
let them go back go ahead
jeff you said the fda is the gold
standard
for ensuring the safety and efficacy of
bad genes to what extent does today's
news add urgency
to the effort of getting a permanent
nominee confirmed
to head the fda you know clearly it's
always an important post
but how much of a spotlight does this
news guys i have no
personal announcement to make today the
fda has an extraordinary group of
scientists and experts
that lead these types of efforts how
helpful would a permanent
director be in those efforts i think
that the
fda does an extraordinary job and
teams that are that are addressing these
issues are experienced teams
in fact the acting director is a very
experienced leader
so i would i think the experience of the
fda
and the expertise of the fda is indeed
the gold standard
are there any immediate plans to
accommodate the states
because of this cause and can you
guarantee that every person at a
reservation
canceled will get rescheduled in a
matter of days
yeah as i said there's i think there's
already in certain locations people who
are scheduled for today
are already rescheduled so we'll do
anything we can to support
the states on the logistics of
rescheduling
and you know at the same time the most
important thing
is that the supply exists uh to continue
to vaccinate three million
americans a day and there's enough
supply to actually accelerate that
there's tens of millions
of doses in the system and as i said
today we announced 28 million more
maternity and pfizer doses are available
to the order this week
last question
you said that there was nowhere to fly
after the other two vaccines
uh this question might be asking you to
be obvious but uh can you verify that
means that there are no developments of
uh
uh symptoms uh the recipients of those
vaccines
there have been no serious events
to call attention to anything that would
relate to a pause
right why would it be in oh i don't
think no one would pick you from the one
vaccine but not the other two why does
that speak to the safety of a few
vaccines
i think you know when you examine
everything in general the fact that you
have
you know 120 million
doses in individuals have received at
least
one dose and as you subtract out of that
121 million
6.85 you're talking about you know 114
or so
million uh individuals have received at
least one dose
and no negative red fails uh red flag
signals
that tells you you're dealing with a
really safe vaccine
and i think you know apropos of several
of the questions that people ask
about hesitancy you know when you want
to talk about safety this is an
extraordinary safety record that the
others
have and the fact that a pause was done
i think just as a testimony
to how seriously we take safety
and why we have an fda in a cdc that
looks at this very carefully
and hopefully we'll resolve it pretty
soon within days two weeks april
of your question so i think it's a very
strong argument for safety
actually thank you thank you thank you
thank you everybody
thank you thank you
they're always welcome always welcome
okay
um i know there's a lot going on today
and you also have a
call time so we will try to get through
as much as we possibly can but i did
want to give you
all a couple of updates um obviously the
president met yesterday with a
bipartisan group of members
uh who are have our work work on
committees of jurisdiction i can talk a
little bit more about that but i also
wanted to give you an
update on the work of our jobs cabinet
which will be very which will be central
to our efforts um and especially in this
period of time where now a lot of these
members are going to go back
uh they're going to work with their
staffs they're going to work with each
other to see what the path for it is
so so far cabinet secretaries from our
jobs cabin i should say
have made 27 calls to members including
seven republicans those are
when they connected of course our
legislative affairs team
has made 139 calls to members their
chiefs of staff and staff directors
35 of those 99 calls to the house were
to republicans
along with 15 of the 40 calls into the
senate this is obviously ongoing and we
will venture to provide you regular
updates so you have a sense of what's
happening
we've held 26 house and senate staff
briefings and nine member level
briefings
including with republican leadership and
five bipartisan groups
and this is clearly picking up senior
administration officials have also
engaged with world leaders faith
communities in the private
sector they've held briefings with
bipartisan groups of over a thousand
mayors and county elected officials and
have had one-on-one conversations with
governors
from both parties i also wanted to
highlight that this week is black
maternal health week
and in its honor today the vice
president and domestic policy advisor
susan rice are hosting a round
table with women who will share their
experiences
with complications from pregnancy child
birth and postpartum
the impact of postpartum uh uh
post post childbirth as well as their
work and advocacy and research
highlighting the disparities that black
women face in maternal
health uh this i think this actually
started around 12 30 so i should say
they've their their the event is ongoing
uh we also announced initial actions we
are taking to address the maternal
health crisis
in the united states including
significant funding to reduce maternal
mortality and morbidity rates
improve health equity and and race-based
disparities nationwide
the approval of the first medicaid
section 1115
waiver in illinois to broadly extend
postpartum coverage
this approval will help ensure access to
vital health care services
promote better health outcomes and
reduce the rate of maternal morbidity
and mortality
and obviously this is an issue we will
continue to work hard on
i also just wanted to highlight that
we're also hosting today
a virtual small business briefing on the
american jobs plan
small business administrator newly
confirmed isabella guzman will join the
event with thousands of small
business owners to highlight how the
american jobs plan supports small
business the plan the president has
proposed
provides direct support to small
businesses by increasing access to
federal
contracts and investing more than 110
billion dollars in financing
and technical technical assistance
programs
um as you know the president also
attended a congressional tribute for u.s
capital officer
william evans this morning he paid his
respects for those of you who didn't
see to officer evans and met with his
family
the president following his remarks i
should say the president offered his
support to the capitol
police who weathered great stress and
responsibility since january's
insurrection
in addition to sustaining the loss of
another fellow
officer finally the president will
deliver remarks tomorrow at the white
house
on the way forward in afghanistan
including his plans and timeline for
withdrawing u.s
troops in close coordination with our
partners and allies
and the government of afghanistan and
his commitment to focusing on the
threats and opportunities we face
around the world today we will have an
advisory with more details out later
today we of course are doing a series of
briefings
throughout the day with all of you and
others i'm going to be uh
limited and what i'm going to share from
here because i don't want to get ahead
of the president but i will look forward
to having a conversation
with all of you in the coming days about
the details of his speech with that go
ahead alex
thanks um let's start with russia can
you share any details on the proposed
summit with
president putin where would it be what
would the topics be and what was his
response
and also putin himself suggested public
talks with biden in mid
march and he was brushed off by the
white house so what's what's the change
what's behind the changing posture
well let me first say that um as as you
note uh the president had a call with
president putin this morning we put out
a readout of that but let me reiterate a
couple of the highlights
for those of you who are following other
pieces of news
during this call they discussed a number
of regional issues
and global issues including the intent
of the united states and russia to
pursue a strategic stability dialogue
on a range of arms control and emerging
security issues
building on the extension of the new
start treaty
president biden also made clear that the
united states will act firmly in defense
of its national interests in response to
russia's
actions such as cyber intrusions and
election interference
and he also emphasized the united states
unwavering commitment
to ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity the president voiced our
concerns over the sudden
uh the aggre of russian military buildup
uh and increasing aggression
on the border of ukraine uh and called
on russia to de-escalate tensions
so as it relates to your question i will
say that um
you know our approach to our
relationship with russia is one where we
certainly expect the relationship to
remain a challenge
we expect there will be continued
difficult conversations
and we are prepared to confront those
but our goal is to have a relationship
with russia that is
predictable and stable and having a
conversation or a dialogue which
the plans will need to be developed on
this is the first conversation
about it at that level of course uh the
purpose of that is to
of course be honest and candid where
there are areas where we disagree and
have concerns
but also work together on areas where
there is mutual interest
and that may relate to uh arms control
as
as we did with the extension of new
start shortly after the president was
inaugurated
or even uh working together on pursuing
an iran nuclear deal so there'll be a
range of topics discussed as we get
closer and details are finalized
we'll share those with you but we're
just at the early stages of the
discussions
with respect to russia's military
buildup at the ukrainian border
what is on the table to respond if
russia doesn't back down i mean
are military options being considered
well
secretary blinken on secretary austin
are both in brussels now
they are having discussions with their
counterparts about a range of topics
including
the military buildup on the border so i
won't get ahead of those discussions i
expect they will do a readout
when those discussions conclude any uh
approach or engagement with russia
or actions would be done in coordination
and one more on afghanistan republicans
are already
talking is that the announcement has
happened of the withdrawal
of all troops by september 11th and so
we wanted to get your reaction to
something mitch mcconnell just said um
he suggested that it would put
our nato partners in a shared fight that
we have not yet won
would abandon the women of afghanistan
whose freedoms and human rights will be
in peril
um he said that the administration plans
to turn tail and abandon the fight in
afghanistan
uh so what is your response to this
criticism and criticism from
other republicans that it's it's too
soon without any plans to
sort of maintain stability there well
again i will
leave it to the president to lay out his
uh specific plans for withdrawing troops
the reasoning and his
commitment to uh focusing on the threats
and opportunities we face around the
world today but i will say that the
president has been consistent
uh in his view that there's not a
military solution
uh to afghanistan that we have been
there for far too long
that has been his view for some time
well documented well reported on
he believes that and he remains
committed to supporting uh
negotiations between the parties which
many of you
may be following are resuming next week
and he also believes we need to focus
our resources on fighting
the threats we face today 20 years
almost 20 years after
the war began uh and so that's his
approach
on how he looks at this decision but he
will lay out more specifics
tomorrow uh hey go ahead thanks jen
you mentioned president biden has been
consistent as a candidate
he told cbs that we thought a smaller
footprint of troops should remain in
afghanistan in the case
that terrorists their capacity and now
he's committing to
drawing troops to a number that is zero
can you explain that change
again i know we're doing a number of
briefings with all of you uh
where you will have all of these
questions answered i will say that
the president's approach and uh his
decision that he made was done through
close consultation with military leaders
uh with his national security team with
partners and allies around the world
uh and with his objective of mine in
mind of ensuring we are focusing on the
threats we're facing
we're doing that in close coordination
with our partners and allies and i will
uh
leave it to the briefings that you will
be receiving and his speech tomorrow to
outline more
in more further detail go ahead oh god
russia
the u.s has repeatedly called on russia
to de-escalate tensions at the ukrainian
border
does the president have any reason to
believe putin will actually listen
this time well i would say when it comes
to diplomacy
you don't stop calling for what it what
are the right actions and the
appropriate actions and the actions the
global community
believes are right uh just because you
see a hesitation in taking those actions
and there is uh what is different now is
that there is
coordination on the international front
uh with
the europeans with our partners as i
mentioned secretary blinken and
secretary austin are in brussels now
having a discussion about a range of
issues including the aggression
at the border uh and that pressure is
different russia is an outlier in many
ways
um in that regard so we will continue to
work in our wood in partnership with our
allies and partners and continue to put
the pressure on and call for what's
right
thank you go ahead a couple of different
topics just one quick follow-up on
russia
in reading the the readout that you guys
sent out does the president currently
characterize the relationship with
russia as honest and stable or that's
something he
wants to work for i think what we're
working toward is predictable and stable
uh we're not we're not looking for a an
establishment of trust as much as a
predictability
uh and stability uh because there are a
range of threats there are a range of
opportunities
in the world and the president wants to
have the bandwidth to focus on them
not on an adversary or relationship with
russia
um you guys have had a little bit of
back and forth the white house in the
michigan governor's office
is the president right now i know she's
an ally kind of disappointed with how
the governor has managed copen in her
state at least late
well let me say uh phil as you know
you've been covering it quite closely uh
we have been at war with this virus for
over a year now and governor whitmer has
been in charge of a state that has been
incredibly hard hit by kovid for that
period of time
and she's done a tremendous job in our
view
while facing an enormous set of
challenges she has been steadfast in her
commitment to keeping the people of the
state of michigan
safe and a tremendous partner in the
fight against kovid
and if you go back more than a year ago
she led that fight to make sure first
responders in the state
had ppe they needed when cases took off
and she pushed for more testing when the
federal government
told governors that they were frankly on
their own and to figure it out on their
own
uh she had had to endure not just a
public health crisis and a hostile state
legislator
slater but friends who have passed from
the virus armed aggression in the state
capital and threats against
her life she's also had to coordinate a
disaster response to a faulty dam burst
all while doing all of this and a
devastated michigan
community so we feel she's shown some
serious grit
fight and resolve we're going to
continue to work with her on how we can
help address
the uptick in her state uh and help
deploy the resources we have available
running full game today um the
president's repeatedly said that he
wants
uh the instruction proposal he's put on
the table to be paid for he's obviously
proposals to pay for it
is that a red line is he open to not
paying for
some of that proposal if that's the
direction congress wants to go
well i'm not gonna his only red line is
in action and
uh he is happy to hear from as he did
yesterday
proposals that members have whether it
is to
uh have a lower increase or yes a lower
increase of the
uh of the rate on corporations uh
whether there are proposals to pay for
uh this plan in a different way he's
open to hearing it uh his starting place
is that
we should pay for it but we're at the
beginning of the discussions here
and ultimately his only red line is
investing in our infrastructure
making sure we are putting americans
back to work over the long term
go ahead sorry miracle back to you on
russia the president of proposing a
summit with vladimir putin would suggest
that
he's looking to de-escalate some
tensions there so
does that mean it's unlikely the u.s is
going to
enact harsher sanctions on russia like
sanctioning their sovereign debt
well uh well i'm not going to get ahead
of uh any announcements we have
on uh the consequences uh that uh
we will invoke on the russian leaders
for the actions they've already taken
no it does not change uh the
calculations the the process the review
that has been ongoing i expect we'll
have more to say soon
and certainly the president uh was clear
that there will be consequences as he
has said publicly
some will be seen and some will be
unseen as we often say
and hopefully we'll have more to share
with all of you soon one on on
nominations
notice that the director for immigration
and customs enforcement was not included
in the tranche that was announced
yesterday
that included cbp and uscis so
why wasn't that person included in that
tranche and when
should we expect to see a nominee for
that position it's a great question i
don't have any personal announcements or
previews
for you uh sometimes we announce things
because they're through the vetting
process and a decision has been made and
uh while it might be cleaner to do it
within a group
we want to get these names out nominated
through the process as quickly as
possible
so hopefully we'll have a nominee soon
go ahead i know you're leaving the
details of this to the president
tomorrow but i do want to turn on just
one
part of this the administration
obviously is committed to supporting
afghan women and minorities what do you
say to people who are concerned that
this
could put them in their lives at risk by
withdrawing
i will say that broadly speaking uh the
president and this administration
supports
women and girls around the world uh we
support it through a range of
actions through a range of initiatives
through a range of programs that we
support we will absolutely continue to
do that
uh the president has been consistent in
his view
that uh there the the there is no uh
viable end to the war a military
violence to the war in afghanistan uh
he's had that view
for some time now and he has to make
decisions through the prism of what's in
the interest of
the national security of the united
states and that includes keeping our
focus
on where the threats are emerging around
the world
whether those are emerging threats from
al qaeda in parts of north africa
or other threats or opportunities we see
in other regions and
hence those are big motivating factors
in his decision
on police reforms and racial justice it
doesn't appear that democrats have the
votes needed to pass
the george floyd policing act as the
administration hopes
is the white house open to negotiations
on this possibly even giving maybe
another look at tim scott's justice act
the democrats blog last year
well we will leave that i know senator
scott senator booker and others are
in close discussion and coordination
about what a path forward may look like
we certainly understand that there could
be changes to
proposals that have been forwarded
before to date uh we believe that the
george floyd
uh act has a lot of the components that
will help
uh rebuild the trust help address put in
place many of the reforms that are
frankly
long overdue so we but we also recognize
that democracy in action means changes
take place so we'll have to see what the
discussions look like and
whether the president could support any
changes that would be made through that
process
i just want to get your reaction to some
comments from congresswoman rashida to
leave that
are getting a fair amount of attention
uh responding to dante wright's shooting
she says i'm done with those
who condone government-funded murder no
more policing incarceration
and militarization it can't be reformed
what do you make of those comments do
you disavow or calls for no more
policing
look what i can state from here is that
um that's not the president's view the
president's view is that
there are necessary outdated reforms
that should be put in place
that there is accountability that needs
to happen that
the loss of life is far too high
that these families are suffering around
uh the country
and that uh the black community is
exhausted
uh from the ongoing uh threats they feel
but he also believes that there is a
forum for putting in place legislation
the george floyd act
that can help put many of these uh
necessary reforms in place and that part
of what needs to happen is rebuilding
trust
in communities uh in order to get to a
better place
glad to see just a follow-up to that
there are people all across the country
who are
demonstrating and actively call it for
reform
what expectation should they have for
change in the bible era
what what is this president going to
bring to bear
if for example qualified immunity isn't
removed from the law if you can't get
that
in a bipartisan agreement well first
we're not going to get ahead of what the
discussions are about a bipartisan
agreement i think what americans who are
exhausted who have suffered who are
worried about their kids and their
family members should know
is that the president sees racial equity
as a central focus of his presidency and
his actions bear that out he has
obviously signed a number of executive
actions
he is a strong supporter of putting in
place working through legislation that
can put in place
permanent reforms and he will continue
to elevate and talk about the need to
address these issues across the country
at a range of opportunities and i
hopefully that gives some reassurance to
the public about his commitment
quick question about yesterday's
infrastructure meeting there were some
rumblings on the hill that one of the
things that was mentioned in the
discussion was an increase in the
gasoline tax
can you explain the context and what was
actually discussed
sure i think that was a little bit of a
garble unintentional but
uh in yesterday's meeting with members
of congress the president mentioned
the gas tax only to make a point that
even a significant increase
in the gas tax some people have proposed
would pay for only a fraction of the
investment the country needs now
fundamentally
he does not believe that paying for this
historic investment
uh in rebuilding our nation's
infrastructure
and creating millions of jobs should be
on the backs of americans so he doesn't
believe that anyway he's proposed his
own means
of paying for it but he was using it as
an example of how it wouldn't even make
a a sizable dent in paying for the
package so it's not under consideration
here correct
correct go ahead andrea the
international friend um you
have tensions obviously uh with russia
over ukraine and crimea
there are a lot of concerns about what's
happening in china and the south china
sea and i'm also
in taiwan um are you
confident is the president confident
that the u.s military is
postured correctly and prepared to deal
with
multiple crises occurring almost
simultaneously at a time when you're
withdrawing troops from afghanistan
absolutely um the president uh has
utmost confidence in uh general austin
and his leadership and secretary austin
i should guess i should say switching
switching titles
uh and he believes we have the best
military men and women serving
uh in the world and so he has absolute
confidence he also believes
that we should leave with diplomacy and
his actions his leadership his approach
uh certainly bear that out just um china
with the climate summit coming up i mean
do you see opportunities to sort of
rebuild the relation or address the
tensions and the
long-standing tensions in the
relationship with china
over the climate summit to sort of use
that as an opportunity to move forward
i we obviously have not made a
determination about bilateral
portions or meetings that would take
place as a part of the summit we've
invited over 40 leaders
but i would say that we are engaged as
you know
at a range of levels uh we are
approaching our relationship as
one uh not of conflict but of
competition we believe that the most
important steps we can take is to
rebuild and support our own economy here
at home
and to also be candid about areas where
we have concerns whether it's human
rights abuses
or i technological abuses
and that is certainly how we approach
our relationship so
while the summit is still coming
together i'm not sure i would go that
far given there are
over 40 leaders we have invited and
we're still finalizing the details of
the
of the events i'm a domestic friend in
terms of the
uh george floyd policing act um
do you anticipate major
protests and riots if depending on the
verdict in the showdown
chopin case and what are you doing to
prepare for that we have
a lot of controversy during the trump
administration about the use of national
guard troops
are you preparing to put in national
guard troops if needed
if the depending on what happens in that
verdict i know it's a hypothetical
question but
you have to prepare for all
eventualities from last night but
or two days ago the president was you
know appealing for calm
mm-hmm can you just tell us walk us
through your strategy and approach
given how volatile the tensions
the situation is well while we are not
going to prejudge the outcome which i
realize you're not asking me to do but
just to
state it clearly we are working with
state and local leaders
to advance our shared goal of ensuring
public safety and citizens rights to
peaceful protest
the president we all will continue to
monitor the developments
and our team will remain in contact with
these officials on the ground as well as
with civil rights leaders
and community stakeholders but i don't
think i'm going to uh read out more than
that uh go ahead rule out standing in
the national guard
i would just leave it at what i convey
go ahead the president's
tax plans he has said that individuals
households
under 400 000 per year aren't going to
see
their taxes go up does that also apply
to
indirect effects from the corporate tax
changes that might not
technically be tax increases like an
average family of four
making under that amount sees their
heating bill go up because
utility companies increase their rates
to accommodate
the 28 corporate tax rate is that okay
or acceptable
to the president you know because it's
not technically a tax increase
well i would say that there's no reason
that that is
what needs to happen we saw we have
evidence of what happens
back in 2017 when republicans prioritize
tax cuts for big corporations over
investing in working
people there were many arguments made
about what the impact would be
the benefits would be passed on to
consumers they would invest in r
d there would be jobs created none of
that happened there were stop
stock buybacks more incentives to
offshore record compensation for
executives we have seen countless
studies where the biggest impact to
these corporations
would likely be on capital so i would
say that's not a concern we have at this
moment in time
but even though i mean utility companies
did maybe is
arguably partially for shell but they
did announce
you know great decreases after the 27
tax law
passed and attributed it to the tax law
passing
is there some data that you're expecting
from economists suggesting that will be
the case or you're just getting ahead of
what might happen when the bill passes
i'm just getting ahead of that like
there were those announcements
you said like they didn't have the
intended effects
but utility companies didn't say
hey our you know we can pass on this
lower rate to consumers
through their utility bills and have
utility companies said i have not seen
it if they have that they would raise
the cost um if this bill passed to
invest in infrastructure and get
let out of the pipes to make sure
there's clean drinking water and create
millions of jobs
i'm not aware of any specific
announcements like that i'm just saying
that was
the one of the results that occurred
after the 2017.
well then i don't think we anticipated
as an issue quite yet go ahead hunts
they've been announced they're going to
go to 60 years in richmond
what does that do to the ongoing
indirect talks does it complicate them
are those talks still on
uh then i'll i'll have a couple
follow-ups sure
uh well let me say that um first we take
seriously iran's provocative
announcement of its intention to begin
enriching
uranium to 60 which the p5 plus one
should be unified and rejecting the step
both calls into question around
seriousness
with regard to the nuclear talks and
underscores the imperative of returning
to mutual compliance with the jcpoa
we share and a common stated objective
of returning to mutual compliance with
the jcpoa
with iran and we have been engaged
constructively in what we felt was
constructive
dialogue last week even as it was
indirect
uh in in vienna um and we while they
were difficult
and while we expect this to be long uh
we expect and we have not been alerted
of any change in planned attendance in
the meetings that will
resume later this week so we are
certainly concerned about these
provocative
announcements uh but our goal remains uh
seeing through a diplomatic process
which we expect to resume
in vienna later this week very clear you
expect to you expect the indirect
negotiations to continue even though
you're questioning their seriousness to
those negotiations
well look i think hans we are we believe
that the diplomatic path is the only
path forward here
and that having a discussion even
indirect is the best way to
come to resolution it doesn't mean that
we hold back on concerns we have and
don't encourage our p5
plus one partners to expressing those
same concerns
and having that as part of the
discussion sort of diplomatic front was
the us giving any heads up about the
attack
from potentially israel on the power
facility for the tops
i have nothing further to um read out
about our
understanding of the origin or the
intention of the
uh attack at all in any way
involved in the attack on the power
facility in the time
as i said yesterday we were not um if i
could just do
we'll switch gears to russia real quick
um the statement said in the coming
months
for this potential summit um is that
going to be this summer
we'll see in the coming months would be
this summer does the president have any
preference on
where the location should be it's a
great question i know alex was asking a
similar one uh we're still just at the
early part of this process
and uh so as we have more details we
will share them with all of you
northern hemisphere i don't think we're
quite there yet
you're sounding like there's a place
you'd like to summer um
with president biden and president putin
i can pass that along
certainly but okay go ahead
hard to follow but i'm sure you have a
very serious and good question go ahead
thanks for that i suppose um my question
is on lgbtq rights
you told me weeks ago uh president biden
stands by his campaign promise to sign
legislation within
100 days uh we are now on day 83
of the presidency and it looks like that
bill isn't close to making it
uh by that deadline and the president is
facing christ with multiple crises as
evidenced
by the questions in this briefing does
the president continue to stand by that
campaign promise
he does uh he continues to work toward
it
uh and as you know in order to sign
legislation it needs to come to his desk
and while he has
certainly been a vocal advocate uh in
his support for the equality act
um he uh and obviously as you know and
noted it passed the house and needs to
work its way through the senate
uh he it requires the senate passing it
in order for him to sign it
what the president's efforts like in
getting out of the senate to
test legislation well certainly he's put
out a statement of administration policy
uh he has talked about
his view that this is legislation that
should pass and
he has a range of conversations about a
range of topics but uh also so does our
legislative team who work to move
forward his agenda every single day
and then one thing that's related to
this is the supreme court's upcoming
decision in the case of
fulton versus city of philadelphia which
will determine whether there's a first
amendment right
to reject child placement in the homes
of same-sex couples
is the administration doing any
contingency planning for that decision
in terms of
the equality act or anything else uh
tell me a little bit more contingency
planning as if what if there's a
different outcome than we would
like from the supreme court ruling um
yeah yeah
it can just be planning based on the
outcome of this decision and how that
occurs with the
uh passage of legislation and i think
some
observers say that one decision or
another might let the air out and
allow and change well actually let's
just change the landscape
for passage of the equality act that's
an interesting question i'd probably
have to talk to our legislative team uh
we typically as you know don't get ahead
of supreme court rulings um
but i will talk to them and see if
there's anything we can convey directly
to you
uh go ahead thank you oh i'm sorry go
ahead i'm just going to keep track so it
gets everybody but go ahead
i have a question on immigration so you
know
with the guatemala and honduras and
mexico deploying their troops off their
borders
what are what is the white house or the
body administration's next plans to kind
of
help mitigate migration at the u.s
mexico border
at our own border well i would say that
part of our effort here in working with
these countries
is uh the recognition that a regular
migration is a hemispheric issue
that requires all countries in the
region to play
their part so part of our effort here
was to work with
mexico and northern triangle governments
uh to implement collaborative migration
measures of course if these are
effective then there will be fewer
people who are coming
to our own border so there is an impact
even of that announcement that we just
made
uh that that that ensures that countries
have deployed
security personnel migration officials
and other officials at the different
border to
at their borders to address migration
and you know last month we saw some
really large numbers at the border of
migrant apprehensions how does the biden
administration working with
local officials with local governments
and local nonprofits along the border
who
some are picking up some some of the
costs like you know um covid
testing and um hotel yeah
but things and so kind of how is the
government working with these local
officials
well they play a a tremendously
important role
um in helping ensure as you noted in
some cases it is
working with ngos and local authorities
and officials on testing
in other cases there are covering the
cost of
hotels and others for quarantining so
they play a
really tremendous role in helping ensure
we are working
in a humane way with those who are
coming
to our border uh in a range of ways now
we continue to convey
uh which is our policy that the border
is not open that we are turning away the
majority of people
uh of adults who come to the border uh
but we still have children
uh we still have uh some migrant
families who mexico cannot accept for a
variety of reasons
and these ngos play an incredibly
important role i know we're at the end
of our time here so let me just
because there's a gather that's why but
let's see if we can just get to you too
quickly go ahead
just a few about the vaccine and one on
lebron if i can um several times from
the podium you've acknowledged that the
biden administration may not be the best
messenger for certain groups on the
vaccine such as
white evangelicals conservative white
folks
can you take us inside the process as to
how you're determining who the best
messengers
are for those communities are you
reaching out specifically to targeted
people are you relying on volunteers
what does that process look like well a
big part of our effort
and i appreciate you asking this
question is um to create impart a
community core
um which is a program that gets
fact-based messages into the hands of
local messengers and what we've seen
through our data
is that local messengers whether that is
elected officials
mayors doctors sometimes clergy civic
leaders are the most effective
messengers
of of anyone um and that's why a large
part of our
uh three billion dollar funding that we
have are
are focused on uh getting out into the
country is on
working with community-based
organizations to strengthen vaccine
confidence
in the highest risk and hardest hit
communities uh so it really depends
community
community but we work with faith-based
organizations we work with
community health workers we work with
disability organizations we work with
organizations across the board of all
different backgrounds and affiliations
so that they can
uh get the message clearly out to
communities how are you determining
which organizations know who these
influential people are who are going to
reach these certain groups that you feel
like perhaps you're not going to reach
how we determine who community leaders
are in communities and like
that you're trying to you know well i
think as i'm conveying here a lot of
this is based on
uh local taking a local uh a role
approach
and it's a lot of it's driven through
hhs so they may be best able to answer
your question i just want to get to our
last person go ahead
from my colleague uh do you have a
comment on japan's plans to release
waste water from fukushima into
uh pacific ocean into the pacific ocean
let me get you a comment from our
national security team after
the briefing i'm happy to do that or
directly to your colleague i should say
did you clarify who initiated the
phone call with president putin was the
president fighting
i don't think i'm gonna have more detail
on that i'll check if i do the last
thing
the last one does president biden want
to restore travel
with between the united states and
europe
as well as with the united kingdom
before
summer you mean as it relates to covet
restrictions
look our focus of course we'd love to
have uh travel return
just like everybody would like to return
to normalcy but we rely on the advice
and the the guidelines uh done by our
health and medical experts and so
we'll defer to them on the timeline for
that see a chance for restoring travel
between europe and the united states
for the summer many people need to plan
in advance
sure we and uh we understand that uh but
also we
will rely on the guidance and the
timeline of our health and medical teams
thanks everyone
you